foreign
foreign
foreign
I'm back with the home base brother
Angel who is yes believe it or not the
actual third Muslim although you might
not have seen him much recently
damn there's a mad Echo bro
me oh it's wait one second
that's coming from me
sorry it sounded funny
I can't see any chat right now too
that's so weird okay there we go
okay guys
so I don't know where that that Echo was
coming from
okay wait
let me try talk again
say something
yeah man
sounds like there's an effect on let me
remove this maybe maybe
it says
quickly uh
yeah yeah one second one second
actually wait actually you can't tell
them because it's a
there's a lag or not a lag and Echo
okay let me
restart it
yeah yeah they they hear the echo they
hear it too
that's so weird
okay
okay I think I think I might have fixed
it Miss Miller let's see
yeah I don't know why it's not up
it is up bro it's just not
chatting
all right they still can't hear you guys
right now
that's weird bro forgive me guys
technical difficulties
I think so I think it's just mine
okay
it's funny
okay uh
okay
try now Bismillah
but now I cannot hear a thing
[Music]
okay bro that's so weird I like I don't
know how else to fix it
oh my God
really no people are saying
that might only be when I switch the
like the input
I'm not sure
[Music]
okay
that's funny no it's okay I'll just um
I'll I'll make it my my speakers and
then they'll probably be able to hear
you through my mic which actually I
guess is a blessing in disguise now
someone talk
okay
I think now they can hear everyone
through my mic
all right welcome back guys hope you're
all inshallah we maintain the 500
viewers through that muscle thank you
guys for sticking around we will begin
now inshallah if you guys did not then
check out our stream which we recorded
live with snico himself
with that being said let me show you
guys a little sneak peek of that
that's not it hold on a second there we
go
in front of myself
right
I've always talked about how
a guy with the most is Islam I have like
Dave Chappelle is
there's some differences
trying to make fun of myself and
self into not fully understanding it go
ahead
Malcolm X was part of the Nation of
Islam but then he left
all right so as you could see sneako he
uh
is very interested in Islam and
rightfully so I mean who wouldn't be
similar sorry technical difficulties
again
so that being said uh actually believe
it or not sneako spoke with Tristan Tate
um apparently about religion I haven't
seen the clip but according to Faya they
spoke about uh about religion
so we're gonna give that a watch we're
gonna react to that as well and insha
Allah both brothers and well all three
including Andrew inshallah will come to
Islam
you guys ready
exactly
people are saying low audio
they're not saying Echo about the single
audio okay how about could not hear
could not hear uh
it's because I'm not sharing my actual
uh
because I'm not sharing my actual things
I think I think
that's funny I I think I know what
happened it just switched one of the
devices to um
to the wrong thing and I don't know why
so okay someone talk now
there we go I think I just I think I
just fixed it
Bismillah okay talk again talk again
all right almost almost there almost
there
okay that's done and then this
okay between uh
um
okay now try Bismillah
oh my God bro never mind no we're not
working sorry guys
my height is irrelevant right now bro
yeah I really don't know what to do let
me uh try and like we can share the mic
like this
yeah I'm four four
okay
I don't want this whole stream to be me
trying to fix this like Fiat said
but at the same time I don't want you
guys to not be able to hear
the brothers
oh I got it I think I think I'm gonna
get it
foreign
yeah bro that'd be really nice
okay let me try switching the sample
rate talk now
bro was that it was it just a sample
rate sorry talk again
foreign
why is it not like showing through the
thing
okay wait no okay now try
hello hello
restart this stream man I think that's a
bit extreme
don't mean to spit bars on you guys but
okay one one more time one more time
I think it worked
did it work guys is it working I think
that's good
they're saying no it doesn't work but I
think that's for the last attempt
yes works yeah so okay thank God
alhamdulillah
all I did was switch the sample rate
back and forth uh so anyways my
beautiful brothers please speak let the
audience hear your normal voices
inshallah
hey
all right Bismillah so without further
Ado Insha'Allah
let us start with this actual reaction
I'm gonna try and share the screen with
you guys I don't think it's gonna work
but
then again maybe it will
you never know
what can you hear me without the echo
bro yeah I just want to give a quick
shout out to over 600 people watching
this may Allah bless you all please
please please please please please
sincerely guys listen we've been doing
this YouTube thing for about a year and
a half so we're still kind of new to
that too but the streaming thing it's
literally it hasn't even been a month
bro yeah so please please apologies
sincerely from all of us for the
technical difficulties may God bless you
all and just just literally thanks for
your patience let us know if y'all want
to see a video game channel
what
nothing don't worry about that all right
and those who cut it cut it if you know
you know
all right Bismillah if you guys can hear
this amazing if not then I did my
absolute best and that's all that
matters proper Muslim
and that's when they that's when I got
fun until did you guys hear that
no no okay well I'll just explain as we
go I've been talking about God more on
my stream and I think it's better for
people to follow that but I'm not sure
what it is I haven't fully decided what
religion I want to join if I if I do I
have a lot of a huge Christian and
Muslim audience
but what do you think God is
see huh that is a very tricky question
for me that is a very tricky question
for me I
initially became so my my religious
story is as follows I was a young kid I
moved to England at eight years old I
came from Indiana
all of my because I'm I'm mixed race and
you know African-Americans are
overwhelmingly Christian I used to go to
those churches with the big fat black
mamas clapping and singing
I see I was the whitest man and I was
the whitest little boy in those churches
when I was a kid and I wasn't educated
on religion that much when I was eight
years old I believed that like a lot of
people in isolated parts of the world do
that before the internet especially that
everyone believed in God and everyone
knew the story of Jesus and everyone was
the same religion I had no concept of
what a Muslim was I had no concept of
what an atheist was and when I was
thrown into uh
when I was thrown into
school in the United Kingdom I was going
to school with Sikhs Muslims Hindus
Etc
and I was like whoa these people believe
in a God that's not God the real one
that's [ __ ] up so as a young kid I
read the Bible I read the Quran I read
this the the guru Grant say the the sea
collie book and I used to engage in
debates with the Muslim kid I remember
his name was wack ass shout out to wack
ass if you're watching this and I used
to engage in debates I tell him why his
religion was wrong and why mine was true
and he told me why his religion was true
and mine was wrong and we have these
these beats in school and I eventually
found myself slipping into atheism I
became an atheist at maybe 12 13 years
old all right so this is some good stuff
so far this is this is definitely some
good stuff so unfortunately guys I don't
think you could hear but basically what
happened was snico introduced the idea
of religion he said he's leaning towards
Islam but he hasn't really chosen yet
and he asked Tristan about his religious
beliefs and he said that his you know
his beliefs and his story um why he
believes well he believes is a bit you
know intriguing so he said that when he
was young he was born basically into
Christianity he said like you know
basically all of African-Americans or a
lot of them are Christian and might I
add the reason for that is because
Constantine went to Africa and coerced
and enforced people African-Americans to
convert to Christianity and it was a lot
of them
actually over time even when they
accepted Islam later on like for example
across Atlantic slave trade they forced
them to adopt Christian beliefs as well
yeah so I mean
you know you know it reminds me of this
quote by the president of Kenya I think
his name was Jomo Kenyatta and he
basically said back in the day before
you know pre-colonization you know they
had the Bible we had the land post
colonization they gave us the Bible and
then they got the land wow
that's crazy man
that's insane that's insane so
yeah that's essentially what happened
and then leading up to now you know a
lot of these families are Christian not
knowing why they're a Christian
initially so can I turn my voice up just
for you my man
Mr Producer Rami that's funny so anyways
uh he was describing how he was born in
Christianity and um he eventually went
to a uh a school I think in the UK and
he was surrounded by a lot of different
Sikhs and Hindus and Muslims in
different religions like what you guys
believe in God that's not actually the
true God like you know what's wrong with
you people and he would debate with
people and he would try and convince
them that his religion was right they
would try and convince him that their
religion was right and that's after
that's right before I started something
to atheism because he read the Quran the
Bible different you know religious texts
and they started to slip into atheism
that's where I paused the video so what
do you guys think about that so far
it reminds me of you bro
how when you had your kind of getting on
Dean's story and you were out here
debating people on the bus and like at
school yeah martial law yeah yeah it
does it does actually resonate with me
uh the difference is because I think
because I was on the truth already it
was just easy for me to go further and
deeper into it and then debate it but
when you're trying to argue something
like Christianity you know someone's
like how can Jesus be God when you know
Jesus had to eat and God doesn't have to
eat you're like you're trying to explain
hypostatic Union and then it's just one
contradiction backed by another
contradiction backed by another
contradiction it just doesn't make any
sense you know I could see why he would
end up falling into uh you know kind of
atheism or agnosticism at least
um
yeah how about uh how about you all know
I don't even say yeah I wanna finish
this into the rest of it yeah and bro is
there a way you can make that you know
how the right now the video that you're
playing from YouTube is the top left
corner yeah is there a way you make that
full screen instead of like so they can
see everything on YouTube yeah when I
play the video I oh I actually open up
the actual browser for them like right
now they can see the browser let's
continue bro all right and also what I'm
gonna do someone suggested uh very big
brilliant idea uh just to turn on
captions
so that's what I'm gonna do here
so hopefully you guys can actually read
the captions like fighting on how you
guys can read the captions as we go
I no longer
all right yeah I'm gonna start the video
again religion and I believe that you
know religion wasn't for me and you know
you don't need God in your life to live
a very happy life until I started to
look around at what other atheists were
doing
it's imagine joining a team
of people essentially and looking around
at your teammates and you see people
bragging about how many abortions they
have people with [ __ ] purple hair
talking about how how being a minor
attracted person or as I like to call
them a pedophile is a sexual orientation
and I was looking around at how atheists
were behaving I thought whoa whoa whoa
maybe I've missed a trick maybe there
was something to this to this God [ __ ]
that I dismissed as a young boy and I I
did further research further research
and I don't believe that any holy book
that I've read in the world I'm not
trying to offend Christians Muslims Jews
Sikhs I don't believe any holy book that
I've read in the world is perfect I
believe that they're all man's
interpretation of the thoughts of God
certainly and
I'm an Orthodox Christian now because I
live in an Orthodox Christian country
this was the religion that was most
accessible to me it was the you know
it's where the churches are it's where
the the priests are in the pastures are
I made I made a bunch of friends with an
Orthodox Christian Church I spend a lot
of time in Dubai I have a massive
respect for Islam I look at the way that
their adulterers behave the way that
they run their families the same with
our Orthodox Christianity the way their
daughters behave the way they run their
families I'll make this there's
something to this this is so much better
than atheism uh I can't advise you on
religious matters because I'm not a
religious scholar this is not a
religious question and um
yeah I don't think it's a religious
question I think it's more of a
philosophical question because my
journey to finding God was pretty much
exactly like yours I I grew up Christian
and then I became an atheist because I
was a big debater kid and I was like why
is the priest gonna tell me all this
stuff he has no life experience all
right I think that's very interesting as
well were you guys able to uh to read
and kind of keep up with it
and yeah I could be in here
wait did you say hear it you could hear
it yeah yeah I could read it and hear it
too bro where did when did this happen
bro alhamdulillah all right I don't have
to I don't have to explain that's great
so subhanallah you know back when he was
saying the whole thing about um he
didn't think any religious text was
perfect and he said that they're they're
definitely like interpretations of the
thoughts of God so one how would you
know that you know that they are
interpretation of thoughts of God how
wouldn't and if they had the thoughts of
God why would they need to interpret it
and not just tell us what the thoughts
are kind of verbatim word for word but
and I think it's funny because he's also
reading all of these texts in English
so they go through an entire
translational era back whenever they
were translated and
um you know
real quick all they see is still the
YouTube view about they can't see us oh
shoot my bad I don't know what happened
I had an entire source for a Discord and
it just like got rid of it I'm not sure
why but bro I have my phone like set to
horizontal and it's showing like it's
all the other like this bro
this whole stream is sideways it's funny
what
all right guys give me uh like 20
seconds let me thank you you can hear me
bro yeah
yeah huge shout out to Brother Ali Chavo
for the Super Chat ancestor Fatima again
for always supporting the channel
what the hell is going on with this do
you have like orientation lock on
nah bro I don't mess around with that
yeah we definitely we definitely got to
address the whole thing about uh you
know no holy book is perfect
and you know we definitely need to
address that oh guys man you know Bliss
is working overtime today on trying to
you know ruin the Stream
all right and there we go I got it now
handila I think that's uh that solves it
so yeah alhamdulillah uh long story
short bro what's up
so don't solve it for me y'all are like
y'all looking
y'all's head like sideways right now I
think the I think discomfort or
displeasure of using a sideways is not
as bad as them seeing that too so sorry
I'm gonna close out this quote
bro it's so it's crazy that this entire
mess of the stream so far we've actually
gained like 300 viewers
but back to the actual point back to the
point all these religions or sorry these
religious texts went through a
translational period or just at least a
translation
so you know the Bible the Quran the Old
Testament everything uh even the Hindu
Vedas they all went through translation
so English readers can be able to read
it
um if he were to read it in Arabic and
understand Arabic I think he would have
no actually I know he would have a
different conclusion because there is no
liter there's no um literature in in any
language I'd say that matches the Quran
so when you read the Quran you're like
this is just this is just elegant the
way it's it's you know certain words are
being used like the I don't want to say
rhyme scheme but the literary devices
that are being used like
it touches your heart and maybe if you
listen to the recitation of the Quran
while reading it he'd feel differently
as well because again he's just reading
an English language like the English
language is a flawed language to begin
with in my opinion because it's so
reductionist it's just so like reduced
you know what I mean like the Arabic
language Chinese these are such vast
languages English is like
it's like a dumb language if I'm being
completely honest no disrespect English
love I'm trying to
be as real as possible here I kind of
know what he means but uh Orthodox
Christian is like the religion that's
most accessible to him right now let me
look man Christianity is the most
accessible religion to me in the West
so I shall be Christian by default then
if that's the most successful religion
you know so then it's like didn't his
brother Andrew say that he's a Orthodox
Christian because
of the the power
people donates twenty thousand dollars
he donates a lot yeah yeah so like at
that point like is it really
accessibility or is it just more of like
um
there's a word for it y'all know the
word I'm talking about here are an
influence
no no no
I get your point bro it's kind of like
friends with benefits
that's funny
um yeah bro like I remember that didn't
survive with me when he's like you know
it's the most successful thing I'm in
Orthodox Christian because that's not
good enough reason bro because by
default then we should be atheist or
whatever you know they're trying to
promote which is always going to change
because of status quo but you know at
the end of the day that's the thing with
Islam doesn't matter where you come from
what religion you're born into what race
or culture you're from at the end of the
day we're all trying to come to this one
straight pad yeah 100 and you know what
I actually on that note I I did
appreciate the fact that he looked at
atheists and what they were saying and
doing and they were like he was like no
that is this I can't believe even if
it's a lack of disbelief you know I
can't join you in whatever you're you're
preaching so maybe there is something
with religion because they looked at you
know religious people and he saw he saw
the you know consistency coherency and
the just the proper way of living
according to him that you know he
witnessed from these people and I think
that's good because I think it speaks to
the fitzro that everyone's born with
that innate disposition that things you
know deep down you know things should be
like this things should be like that
this that just doesn't feel right
and I do appreciate that from him and I
think it's good because it shows that
religion to an extent is supposed to be
pragmatic it's supposed to be something
that is is you know physically
beneficial it's supposed to be something
that is efficient that is you know it's
just practical it's supposed to be
practical and um
maybe some religions are some religions
aren't Allah but that's why you know
when you look at Muslims and not every
Muslim is practicing obviously not every
Muslim Nation or Muslim majority country
is practicing but that's why when you
look at Muslims you can see Customs
Traditions that you can appreciate
because the religion itself is practical
and I'm excited to see what sneako and
him have to say like later on in the
video uh quick thank you to the super
chats
been to awesome may Allah bless you
thank for the ten dollars Ali chabar
always come in clutch thank you for the
10 or sorry for the 100.
10 times 10 my bad uh Mars Abdul thank
you uh he says for the sake of Allah may
Allah reward you and accept it and
multiply it for you
immensely I mean
I mean I'm gonna be honest if you want
to do something actually no no I don't
want to discourage anyone but there are
many Charities that are great to donate
to speaking of that inshallah we're
going to be doing a uh some kind of
Charity very soon with Brother Ali
chobar so stay tuned for that inshallah
but with that being said any other
thoughts before we get back to the uh
the video Let's Dive Right In boy all
right
and then the same thing I just left New
York City but New York City is a very
Godless place people running around
purple hair like literally doing dances
for how many abortions they've had and
they're changing their gender their the
pride month Sue is like one of the
biggest sins if you think about it pride
is one of the biggest sins they have a
whole month to celebrate it so there's
there's all this Godless behavior and
you're seeing how it's changed and so I
would say my journey to finding God's
the same as yours I look at religious
people and I'm like there's something to
this but my uh I'm conflicted because I
think of something like God and I think
of how religions call it like God is the
father and we're supposed to fear God
and even in my head like the fact that
God has a gender makes no sense to me I
think of it as a as a spiritual thing so
I I'm wondering what you define God I
think God is is everything good in the
world God is love God is the connection
between people is that what you think
too
God God is God is powerful
and I know that a lot of people watching
this will be atheists so I don't want to
tell anyone what to believe in and I I
don't really want to talk about my own
personal religious convictions that much
so let me just give a message to any
atheist out there or let me give you a
message to my previous atheist self I
would certainly say this God is powerful
God is absolutely and ultimately
powerful and whether he is real or not
before you start looking into what God
is and trying to find God look at the
power of God look at how God influences
societies influences people creates
better people God's power is certainly
real within all of us if you if you let
it in and um
yeah I don't want to talk about my own
personal religious convictions too much
but yeah God is powerful and God very
much is real whether you want to believe
in him or not because I've seen it it's
probably the best way to to raise a
child is is with some sort of
all right what do you guys think of that
um
I've I've heard this a lot bro on a lot
of different channels talking about
God's power and the idea of God and I
just don't want brother Tristan Tate
because again he's he's too smart bro
he's too smart to become one of these
people that look at God as like an idea
as like an overarching concept to create
better humans yeah I want them to
understand that yes God actually does
exist it's not like the idea of it that
leads us to you know have better lives
and only leave it at that
on Hell bro
man
I'm trying to correct this scene because
I was doing the damn thing I'll be right
back I'm gonna close out no worries bro
no worries so what about you what do you
think yeah I want to give a few my
thoughts so subhanallah I think that
it's it's it's good again that he could
see religion is practical God is you
know God's um you know rules and um his
Commandments are supposed to be
practical it's supposed to be beneficial
it's supposed to be good like um sneaker
was saying God is good and all that
stuff anything that is good that is God
I want to comment on that later because
obviously you know we disagree with that
statement and I think a few other things
that he said
um but how would you know what God is or
who God is or how God is without God
telling you let's be honest you could
say God is love or God is wrath or God
is this or God is that and by the way
all of them fall short because if you
look at God capital letter g definition
of God
it doesn't make sense that you limit God
by saying he's like death for example oh
God is death well you can't have death
without life really if you think about
it you can have a state of non-existence
but you can't have death or dying
without life so all the all like
automatically your definition of God is
a limited one
because you can't have that without the
other God is love well can you really
have love without hate so do your God
exist if hate doesn't exist so it does
not make him dependent as at least as a
concept that doesn't make sense God is
the one who has no limitation and his
definition is not a limited one it's not
he's four sides and four corners like a
square it's uh one of un of unlimited
unlimitedness basically God is unlimited
he's defined by a lack of limitation he
can do anything he's all-powerful he's
all-knowing he's all wise he's so on and
so forth as soon as you start defining
God by he can't
by virtue of his own existence then
you've kind of already failed
in my opinion
so
I think if you're going to prove God it
has to be in a way that is is a bit more
definitive like sneako said it's a
philosophical discussion so this would
require philosophical arguments
um you know you can't prove God really
by being like well look at this cup
there's a cup therefore the god you
can't look at anything in the world and
do that therefore God you you can argue
you can make a good case there's
intelligent design
that would entail a designer and that's
the most logical you know solution to
this this issue of why are there things
that are designed so you know properly
with a nice beautiful pattern or some
pragmatic efficient you know use or
capability that is you know a pretty
good argument in my opinion but to have
something definitive you need a
philosophical argument like the
contingency argument which I do want to
give the sneak on inshaallah
but um yeah so no
I would I would invite everyone to think
about the abrahamic experience
were the prophet Abraham peace be upon
him he was reflecting on on what God was
and he looked at if please correct me if
I say this wrong book because I'm sure
one of you know this better or the
viewers you all might know it's better
um but he was looking at the sun and
he's like ah the sun is just so Grand
it's so powerful it's amazing the sun is
my God but then when it became night
time he's like wait but the sun's not
here like if if the sun left
then it can't be my God it's it's not it
so he looked at the moon and then he's
like ah the Moon look how amazing the
moon is it just shines it's so beautiful
and it's so Grand and this this has to
be it like this is my gut but then the
moon went away and then the sun came
back and then he kept doing these
deductions back and back until he
finally got to the conclusion of what
God actually was
yeah 100 and obviously we don't believe
that Abraham actually believed these
things like he actually believed the son
was God or anything he was the scholars
say he was doing this to show his people
that what they're saying makes no sense
you know imagine you believe your people
believe the son is God and the Moon is
God and someone comes to you and they're
like oh yeah I believe it's God bro did
it just set where bro your God just left
what did he go sleep is it set it's not
here anymore he's like I can't worship
that he's like I don't worship things
that set that disappear
um and I think that is very powerful
that is very powerful I think that's a
great point masha'allah Let's uh let's
end off the video here
religious morals but I I just personally
ask you that if you want to talk about
something else but I just personally
asked about that because that's the same
reason that I try to I just see all the
good that it does and I see that I
acknowledge that as the right thing to
follow but I still struggle trying to
find some sense of
what is this really what is God but yeah
I understand
yeah it's it's a tricky question for me
I'm for me I'm a Christian I have a
massive Muslim fan base
um and I have a lot of young Muslim kids
who follow me and ask me for advice Etc
and what I always say to them is this
and I mean this with all of my heart I
know Muslim religious Scholars and I am
not one I respect Islam massively but if
you want to learn about uh Islam or if
you want to follow Islam I am not your
your hero because I'm not actually a
Muslim I respect the [ __ ] out of you let
me handle with the let me handle the
people who dislike Islam let me talk to
the Christians and the Jews and the
atheists who dislike Islam and talk them
round if you want information on your
own religion and people to follow there
are millions thousands hundreds of
thousands of Islamic scholars who know
much more than me who can educate you on
your religion much better than me I'm a
Christian I follow Christianity uh wow I
don't want to pause so soon to the end
close to the end
hmm But bro honestly mad respect him
because there's a lot of arrogant people
that would love to just inflict their
own beliefs and ideas onto the religion
be like be like this be like that blah
blah this is what Islam is that's what
slam says
I actually respect him very much for
saying that he oh 100 he is not arrogant
enough to just you know Implement his
own beliefs onto onto Islam he is Masha
Allah humble enough to say I don't know
I'm not a Muslim you have the most
Islamic scholars go to the scholars
that's exactly what we tell people when
they ask us fake questions questions
about rulings is this Halal is that
Haram so on and so forth when we don't
know
yo this this reminds me and and I say
this you know no disrespect to Young Don
bro may Allah guide you listen we still
have
hopes and and aspirations for anyone
that's not Muslim may Allah got them all
but it reminds me of these comments bro
when the whole fias going down people
were like young Don became an Islamic
scholar overnight and it's just an
example A lot of people are like what
Rami is saying a lot of people a lot of
influences it gets to their head bro you
know and it's coming from a very humble
and Pious place when Tristan said that
I'm not your hero if you're looking at
me as like the Pinnacle of like Islamic
scholarship it's not I'm not so you know
I'm a Christian and he made that very
clear and I like that 100 I think that's
beautiful masha'allah I had to apologies
to make you know that comment on this
yeah
um and I'd rather people ask me about
that but you know I love Islam I love
Christianity and it's uh
atheism sucks atheisms for nerds yeah I
don't want to be an atheist nerd anymore
because that's when I feel I had no
purpose had no direction in life and
this has given me more purpose and more
it's I feel more alive believing in God
and believing in good I agree
wow all right Bismillah is it that is
amazing subhanallah that's crazy bro let
me stop sharing this because we're done
with the reactions for now it's not a
lot I mean bro
I just want to get this out of the way
before I forget if a person wants to you
know
determine which religion is true
you would have to look at the text look
at the arguments for that religion and
see which one stands if any of them
stand when you go to Islam and I'm only
going to talk about Sam because I'm a
Muslim I don't waste time with you know
talking about other religions we can
talk about Christianity all that stuff
but another day inshallah
and I would love to get both of them or
either of them on the podcast shallow to
talk about this I think that'd be a
great great conversation but let's look
at Islam Islam has prophecies and
arguments even within the Quran for
example
Allah says in the Quran that if this had
been from anyone other than God you
would have found in it many
contradictions meaning it's from God
there won't be contradictions go try and
find a contradiction if you think you
found one because it's in English then
go ask a scholar see if it's a
contradiction you won't find one I've
actually been trying myself I have
genuinely been trying since I started
practicing when I was 16.
I couldn't find one I thought I found a
few and then when you go to the Arabic
you dig deeper you look at the
definitions of these words it's not a
contradiction and it's just very silly
David wood type arguments the Quran says
that we have sent the reminder the Quran
and we will surely preserve it when you
look at the for example the sanat
manuscripts and other manuscripts you
have manuscripts like from Surah Surah I
think surataha
I think is what it is you see word for
word letter for letter what they have in
that manuscript is the same exact verses
and words and letters that we have in
our Quran today and um uh what's the
brother's name
um Adnan Rasheed he's actually studying
this stuff he has many videos on that so
we know the Quran has been preserved as
well
then you look at for example the the
challenge in the Quran you know if you
believe that this is you know if you
don't believe this from God just bring
one chapter like it bring one chapter
like anything in the Quran the shortest
chapter in the Quran has 10 words
10 words three verses right and like
over 20 literary devices over 20
rhetorical devices including prophecy
bring something like that bring the
equivalent to that and people will say
well it's just based on you know
subjective belief you believe that
sounds nice I believe this sounds nice
I'm not talking about which sounds nicer
I'm talking about how many literary
devices it uses if it's in line with uh
you know grammatical literacy in the
Arabic language or in whatever language
you're you're using so on and so forth
you will not find the equivalent to that
you'll find the equivalent to
Shakespeare you'll find the equivalent
to Eminem you'll find the equivalent to
Picasso and other artists you will find
that you know even computers can
generate pictures nicer than some
artists nowadays like you'll find these
things you will not find out for the
Quran you will not find the equivalent I
challenge you guys go try and find the
equivalent you will not find it even
from one chapter of the Quran and then
on top of all of that you have actual
prophecy